ends because in the previous paragraph
he said that well palmistry looks at the
the hand but just as something purely
external but really the hand is
something inner when it comes to an
individual's fate their Destiny what it
is that they are to be which includes
not only you know whether they're rich
or poor but what kind of relationships
they have what what sort of actions will
be determinative of them will they be a
thief will they be a king will they be a
great lover will they be unhappy or
destitute you know all these sorts of
things are a person's fate and if we
think about this this is a bit of an
aside
it's not as if we have our own fate
totally in isolation from everybody
else's fate that we could possibly think
of in the world
um but that's something that we can hold
on to it and come back to later
we see in a person's face whether they
are in Earnest
Ernst
about what they're saying or doing
or at least we think that we do right
that's why we are so subject to being
um
taken in and sometimes manipulated
because
um sometimes we mistake these things or
sometimes people are actually fooling us
Hegel is going to talk later In this
passage about the difference between the
face itself and a mask that is covering
it up and the fact that the the human
face can in fact become a mask and
there's a little bit of a digression
but this is not something that is
totally unique to human beings as a
matter of fact we see this running
throughout the animal kingdom the
pretense to be something other than what
one is or to dispose of of one's body in
ways that that convey a message
different than what one
really means right so territorial fights
where the the the two sparring or in
terms of mating right
um don't actually try to hurt each other
even though they could very easily think
about boxing their antlers clashing them
together be a lot more rational if they
wanted to get rid of the competition
just Gorham right like a bull Gores
somebody but they don't do that so they
smack these together and they do that
thing and we could go on and on and on
if you think about other animals that
are particularly good at uh mimicry and
manipulation of their environment like
what the most intelligent intelligent of
invertebrates the octopus and we can go
on and on and on
so
handling so what Hagel is doing here is
making a very clever joke that works on
on two levels it it you know sort of a
beginning and ending of the paragraph
but it also illustrates what the
paragraph is talking about if somebody
wants to say oh yeah I can tell what
kind of person you are I know exactly
how you're going to react and then you
go up and you just pop them one right uh
he said were you expecting that you know
there's there's something to that what
is that that that punching the other
person right it is not simply the
passive way in which the body exists
it's very active now you say it's
reactive right you get angry at the
person you know and and maybe if you
have you know the the criminal cast that
that a lot of people who are using this
kind of research were particularly
interesting oh yeah I expected that of
you
um but it would still nonetheless stem
from the person's agency and freedom and
agency and freedom which this is
something we can generalize about human
beings at least when it's experienced
some Freedom doesn't like other people
taking away its freedom and showing it a
fundamental kind of disrespect so it
responds as Lichtenberg says you know
with a good punch in the ear punching
somebody in the side of the head or
maybe smacking them you know that way so
why is Hegel saying this put putting
jokes aside and funny images
what is he after here he says that we
have to consider where the real being
the varus zyme the true being of the
person resides so he says what's going
on is we've got a science of mere
subjective opinion we've already talked
about this subjective opinion being uh
you know Laris mynum uh intention saying
that something is is that way asserting
it drawing conclusions about you know
the person's appearance
and this so-called science this what we
nowadays call pseudoscience he has been
saying that the reality of a person is
their face or their clothing or their
skin color or the bones you know in in
their their skull or their genetics or
and we can go on and on and on and on
right
so
what can we draw from this that's what
physiognomy is saying the real being of
the person consists in the real being
also
you know what's inside the person but
that's gotten to from this outside so he
says
so interestingly here's an implication
this is a little bit of a digression
here
if hegel's correct in this
this means that the whole question of
whether Consciousness is reducible to
the brain or whether you know we have
something like a Cartesian dualism where
there's spirit and then you know the
corporeal organ
that's kind of a non-starter actually
within the hegelian framework because of
course you have an organ
but that organ itself can be understood
in two ways in an objective way which
treats it essentially as a dead thing
even if it treats it as a supposedly
living system and then
the other way which is to say it is it
is infused with or it is integrated with
spirit and not just in like in a high
performing individuals everybody
so he goes on now I mean consider that
too another digression
Hagel has no problem with a sort of
evolutionary perspective on the
development of human being and all that
at a certain point we get a creature
whose brain function is able to be a
sufficient vehicle
for Spirit for geists
for something that we could never guess
would have come on the scene and we we
get to know sort of according to Hegel
after the fact after it's gone through
its process of development keep that
think about that a bit